and lo and behold here you see on the
bodega you see I'm here at Lindsey
Graham oh my god so tell us about
Brendan I mean you want bored with this
idea I think you were one of the people
also thought it was a pretty good idea
well here's what I think you can be the
former CIA director and a critic of the
president you just can't lead the
resistance movement at the same time if
you look at CIA policy about how a
former director should act he is well
over the line yeah well they have
actually a policy about this yeah we had
a history of lying about the Senate
investigation what he what woody on that
about what he did with the the Senate
staff is they were spying on the
computers that sent lied about it and
Dianne Feinstein found out that this
administration share anything with him
as much as he hates them he really
thinks Trump is worse than every enemy
we have so I just think the way he's
carried himself hurts the intelligence
community let's talk about your idea for
a special counsel yes investigate the
Justice bar how would that work and what
are your ground well number one I'm
tired of getting on TV telling you all
the bad things I want somebody who's not
a politician let's put the shown the
other foot what do you think Democrats
would be saying if a Republican if the
RNC hired a former British agent to go
to Russia to get Clinton dirt on Clinton
do you think they'd be wanting to look
at whether or not there was a crime if a
FISA warrant was issued based on a
document prepared by a foreign agent
that's a bunch of political garbage so
I'm tired of telling everybody in the
country how bad this is have somebody to
do for the FBI and the the FISA warrant
process what Muller is doing for Trump
what would it entail and who would who
would be subject to this review within
you can't investigate the whole FBI but
there's a core within the FBI Bruce or
the fact is he ever still have a
security clearance I mean I guess he
does because they're cleaner email
investigation was a joke from the
beginning were in the tank they had a
bias against Trump in for Clinton and if
you had done what she had done you would
you would not we would not be taught but
you still be a member of the jail I
would be court-martialed right there are
people sitting in jail doing far less
than her so I want somebody to look at
how the the Clint
investigation was conducted why it was
dismissed in the FISA warrant every
American should be concerned about the
rule of law and I think the FISA warrant
process here was horribly abused and
maybe in a criminal fashion could could
the judges who were sitting in reviewing
that application for the search warrant
for the for the wiretap of Carter Paige
is there any process within the FISA
courts to review that again I mean if I
were the judge and they didn't tell me
that the opposition candidate not just
an opposition but the candidate paid for
that dossier which was a critical part
the most credit so there's a footnote in
there there's a reference that this guy
may have political motives they never
told the court that he was on the
payroll of the deans what about that
judge what about the judge judge and
judges who I would be really upset but
couldn't I guess there's no way you know
where to go back an unwire tap somebody
but there should be like sanctions and
there should be an ability to issue
sanctions against the Justice Department
officials who signed off on this
Authority has to watch those who watch
us and mr. Horwitz is a good guy but he
doesn't have the power of a prosecutor
the corruption of the Department of
Justice and the FBI regarding the
Clinton email investigation the early
stages of the Trump Russia investigation
were corrupt to the core and I think
somebody needs to look at it outside of
politics especially if mr. Rosenstein is
watching what more has to happen for you
to be convinced that somebody outside
your organization needs to look to make
sure that we clean up the mess James
clapper tonight said our discussion of
this the constant criticism of FBI and
Intel is undermining those hallowed
institutions let's watch but I spent a
good part of my life 50-plus years 34 of
it in the military defending this
country and its values and standards and
institutions which I feel as do the
others involved here are under serious
assault and this is going to get worse
before it gets better I predict so it's
Trump's fault or Republicans fault for
questioning how this whole investigation
how the special counsel was appointed
comb
setup with the whole thing I mean you
can't question if you question that
you're undermining the authority or
integrity what about the integrity
undermined by them what bothers me is no
one Democrat seems to be concerned that
the people in charge of the Clinton emo
investigation clearly were in the tank
for Clinton and hated Trump nobody seems
to be concerned that a political
document prepared by a political party
using a foreign agent to go to a foreign
country to get information a political
candidate was used to get a warrant
nobody seems to be concerned about I met
in the military 33 years I love the FBI
I'm very concerned about what I've seen
senator birth tourism in the United
States birthright citizenship the
president hasn't talked all that much
about that it did on the campaign should
it's become a huge problem in this
country ads in Russia and China will get
you a u.s. passport come here have a
baby we'll put you up we'll find your
doctor we'll get your passport made for
your baby bingo it's done how does this
get turned around well I think you need
to change the laws I mean if you go to
France and have a child you're not a
French citizen but people abuse our laws
they actually get tourist visas close to
the delivery date they come to a resort
with a maternity ward
just to have the child in America well
we we would be a citizen we want to have
you back to get into that further
because I think it is a massive massive
scandal thank you so much senator Graham